أعتقد أن الناس غالبًا ما يتفاجأون بمدى
إعجابهم بالرقص الاجتماعي وأعتقد
أن هذا يأتي فقط من حقيقة أن
الانتقال مع أشخاص آخرين والرقص
معًا في شراكة هو شيء
قمنا به خلال آلاف السنين
حتى نتمكن من التعامل مع هذا العالم ومحاولة
من أجل البقاء على قيد الحياة
[موسيقى]
هناك بعض الأدلة على أن
الرقص الاجتماعي قد يكون مفيدًا بشكل خاص
للدماغ الذي تتعلم منه الخطوات التي
تحرك بها جسدك وأنت تتواصل
اجتماعيًا وهذا أمر مفيد في التنشئة
الاجتماعية ، والتمرينات المتحركة كلها
أشياء  قوية جدًا في
منع التدهور المعرفي ،
فأنت تريد أن تمارس الرقص الاجتماعي
لأنك تريد أن تكون القطعة الاجتماعية
عنصرًا أساسيًا عندما
يتفاعل الناس مع بعضهم البعض ، فأنت
تحفز الدماغ الذي تستخدمه هذا
الدماغ الذي يساعد على بناء ما نحن
اتصل بـ cognitive Reserve ، نحن لا نعرف
بالضبط كيف يعمل التمرين ولكننا
نعلم أنه من خلال تحسين وظيفة القلب والأوعية الدموية ،
قمنا بتحسين التروية للدماغ ،
فإننا نمنع السكتات الدماغية
والنوبات القلبية ، وهذا بالتأكيد يمكن أن يساعد في
منع الخرف التنفس
الكبير ستة سبعة ثمانية أوه واحد هنا
هو بحث يقارن الرقص
بأشكال أخرى من التمارين ، وقد تم
إثبات أن الرقص
مفيد جدًا بالتأكيد
وله تلك الصفات الفريدة للموسيقى
وتعلم تسلسلات جديدة تعمل مع
شريك القدرة على التفكير
والقيام في نفس الوقت  الوقت الذي تستغرقه هذه الأنواع من
الأشياء التي تشغل الدماغ على
مستوى أعلى من مجرد المشي أو
ركوب الدراجات هو الشكل المثالي
لإعادة التأهيل المعرفي الذي نراه
يمكن معالجة الاكتئاب ، ونحن نرى
أنه يمكن تحسين نوعية الحياة التي
نراها
يمكن تحسين احترام الذات ، إنه آمن ، إنه فعال ، إنه
ممتع ،
يجب على الجميع التفكير في تجربته
وإعطائه دوامة